hello my name is markiplier i'm the
youtuber but i've always fascinated
myself with the idea
fascinated myself
that's probably fine i've always been
fascinated with the idea of what if i
was a streamer
it could have happened so if i a
youtuber go into this idea of being a
streamer what is going to happen and
there just so happens to be a simulator
game called streamer life simulator
that's
[Music]
wow all right
really uh starting off with a blank
slate so i'm gonna try to i'm gonna try
to mimic this as much as i
why is the camera drunk why wh why
stop okay where's my skin color
[Music]
no
no
oh my god
whatever it doesn't matter arm length
arm with oh
belly size a big breast size huge titum
uh height let's not get ahead of
ourselves here go perfectly average feet
size uh biggums
smallms
ah no let's keep
we're not going for a space marine here
pretty decent hands legs
jesus christ shirt type default there's
three shirts that's all you get what a
shirt am i wearing i'm wearing a picture
right now okay hair luscious
rebel pompadour middle ager
where's the quarantine
are you sure about these
manly beer the what what pant pants
shorts
sure you know what
sure okay i did it man that took forever
also that music was horrible hello hi
how you doing
chica you look different
how are you doing colt never mind cold
my name is mosey oh no talk to mosey oh
you're not my dog oh okay but you're
still cute anyway up to open your phone
welcome 9 15. okay that's great man time
is moving quick all right put that down
i guess
uh
jeez all right where's my streaming life
begin
uh
yeah gunshots i heard some gunshots
mosey are you okay jesus christ i
thought there was no bullet in the gun
perfect joke fool where's my computer
computer is in front of the door now
[ __ ] off okay thanks mosey man i love
you whoever you are if we're even
related legacy monitor get in your hand
and press a hold put in the bag
motherboard simple mouse old case well i
mean seems pretty decent start i guess
but computer oh
i see i see so if i'm gleaning anything
from the context clues here there's been
some kind of zombie apocalypse and the
only way to survive is to stream to the
other people who are in their hideouts
during the zombie apocalypse okay anyway
i'm gonna go home where was i
who's mosey oh i'm driving actually this
is
this seems excessive in a streaming
simulator game but
i'm going home
god
well that was fun hey everybody is it
karma getting up in here
all right
and i park and then i'm guessing i
set up your computer set up and run your
computer set setup
well you know everyone's got to start
somewhere so i'm going to start here
okay
i guess in here yeah this seems good bam
love it that's great plastic chair you
know what i started with a kitchen chair
for a long time so plastic chairs no
problem who needs lumbar support i don't
even have a mouse pad that is the
biggest tragedy of all i guess you know
at the end of the day they really got
authenticity here uh because this is the
start of every streaming career you
gotta set up every single component and
that's
that's attention to detail right there
see to start computer
look at that old boot screen
look at that look at the way the screen
pops out in front of that that's super
weird
blender
internet actually takes time
i should do my toilet urgently what are
you talking about this is so good but i
have to i'm gonna piss my pants
apparently i'm gonna go
[Music]
hi
hi how are you doing i'm gonna go find a
toilet uh hey zambazor you got toilet i
don't have one in my house would love to
get a toilet you got turlet in here
why do you have a bed there this is how
you sleep
oh my god he's dead oh my god that is a
corpse standing up okay anybody got a
toilet that i can use because hi ice
cream man who's the same man from the
other like a toilet mind if i break
anything you use your toilet can i use
your toilet
what is this building what is this
what is this
what is this
i'm gonna piss myself but that's how you
start this is very meticulous
okay
zornhub
shouldn't go here all right
membership
remember him
this is it
i don't know i'm disappointed okay
microphone
hmm
i always emphasize getting a decent one
that's not too pricey i doubt all those
but this one looks pretty good and at a
discount okay
cart complete payment i am running low
on money and now apparently i need to
send all my money to my credit card
which seems like a bad idea send it all
oh i'm
very broke i know i'm very hungry i'm
getting to it a banana spl clam soup
i'll take one miso soup a melon bread
a nabe and a parfait for me please
complete payment and apparently it's on
the way
i need a turlet or my bladder is gonna
kaboom and i'll piss everywhere turl it
where's the cheapest one furniture for
your dream out just give me the cheap
one oh my god turlets are so expensive
turlets are so expensive why would i buy
the expensive turlet i cl i'm gonna go
bad
good night
well
farting that's so funny
all tutorial missions are complete so
now i begin my great
wow
all right parfait up good breakfast for
me miso breakfast okay miso is
nutritious nabe okay those are
nutritious and i should do my toilet if
only it ever showed up
i need better upload
i know i don't have a toilet it's fine
but i don't want to splurge right away
but i have a so you know i'm gonna go
for the i think i need the upload i need
the upload speed because without the
upload speed i'm kind of going to be
screwed right
look at the speed
look at the blazing speed i need a
camera as well because if i don't have a
camera then how people are going to be
able to see my beautiful face right hey
okay let's just do the cheapest one i
don't know who knows when it's gonna
come here
when's it gonna show up maybe i could
get like a job
jack
horse job king there's gotta be like a
job i can do i have a car
so i can do something like that looks
like for the time and money pizza is
gonna
courier
less energy i don't know what energy
means do i have energy is energy a thing
i have energy is the thing i have oh
is that like 12 o'clock 215 okay so this
is only two hours ah that that sounds
good when does my stuff get here from
zamasu how do i get it how do i get it
i'm gonna go to sleep i'm gonna hope
hopefully it'll be here tomorrow i'm
where's my toilet oh
that's a big webcam
microphone toilet that's a fair
that is fine to find us fine hello buddy
nice ass okay i'm gonna put my turlet
right by the window so everyone can see
it
so it's very convenient turl it bam i
need to go to the toilet
i need
well
i didn't get it all out
why did i need to do that twice is that
my alarm for my job
am i about to job
your pizza job will start at 12 please
be at work
what do you mean at what
where where where's work where's my work
i thought this was going to be about
streaming but i guess this is part of
the deal where's my job is that p i i
think i see pizza down there okay i
gotta go to my job this isn't just
streaming simulator this is life
simulator do i have gps or anything like
that do i do i know anything about where
i'm going can i just have this up while
i'm driving i'm gonna deliver pizzas
probably and then i'm gonna get some
money so that i can get a
my stream off the ground which i can do
because now i got a microphone oh my god
i'm gonna be late two hours was not
enough time when time goes by a minute a
second oh my god i'm late i'm late for
work oh i'm late for my j-o-b job come
on i can cut through here right this is
okay this is cool all right cool thanks
is this it
panuchi's pizza
panuchi's pizza panuchi's pizza oh it
says right here
oh
what do you mean workers already about i
couldn't get here in time well at least
give me a pizza
okay okay all right let's just try to
stream okay let's just try to do that
i'm gonna get dark souls that'll be the
first game that i play dashboard stream
name uh markiplier's big stream debut
okay my subs are
kings baby stream key one four three
four
approve okay
now ops is ready to go and now everyone
knows my stream key who's watching this
which is a problem we're just chatting
oh god i'm not
i don't have a camera so
how long did you take dumb oh i hadn't
even downloaded it let's just start a
stream
you need a microphone i have a micro i
didn't set up that microphone there we
go my oh that's my microphone okay it's
just gonna be right here okay it's gonna
be pointed at me right there okay cool
we got it okay let's start stream
hey
what's going on guys it is your boy
markiplier here you know just chatting
i knows watch the stream uh speak to
yourself i talk to myself all the time
it's fine you know uh
my dudes i love
everything i got
silent i guess this is not stream this
is garbage i'm aware of that i'm aware
i got dunny
i got a donation anyone watching this
stream is an idiot well you're here too
so thank you i saw the ip address i will
send ddos thank you very much appreciate
that saw me outside today hey thank you
so much really appreciate that
talk about artistic
what
what
oh
it's like uh what's up who's it it's
like the thingamabobby uh the the thing
the thing am i still streaming i'm not
streaming anymore i got hacked i'm out
of energy well
that was a good stream guys
did i
get paid if the incoming donates are
over ten dollars we instantly transfer
paid why would i work a job at like a
pizza place when i could do this i made
39 bucks just showing my desktop and
being a badass i am the greatest
i am the best
i am fantastic you all suck compared to
me i'm hungry i'm gonna go
get some food i think i saw an atm over
here this is very strange this game is
like made like ass but also it's made
very well
in terms of like the detail very
surprised hey can i get some food i'm so
hungry
streaming is so hard
thank you
okay
i got a message i think
your job will be there at 12 your
employer can rate your work okay i'll do
that okay let's just go let's oh my god
i gotta get my phone
oh my god left left left left okay
life is so hard oddly enough the easiest
part about this is the streaming i had
12 viewers on my first stream that's
nuts
that's nuts
okay
all right i'm here early this time i
actually made it in time
with the handbrake on
this isn't
hard are you okay ma'am
i feel so dirty i have to take a shower
i know but it's
baths are expensive i have to wait do i
have to wait until exactly 12 if it's
like on the dot what are you looking at
ma'am
okay 23
oh i can start early
i'm done 82 bucks
that was per hour
oh
i made 82
i'm gonna be able to take a shower maybe
i don't know
i'm almost out of gas
oh my god oh my god everyone just almost
dies here everyone hey can i get a
can you top her off i hope it's not more
than 20 bucks because that's what i got
there's so much money for gas you
kidding me i'll take out all the money
that i just spent or that i just made
and i will pay for
gas like college all over again okay i'm
gonna
there we go i got half half a tank i
need a shower so bad but the stream
grind never ends my dudes it never ends
let's do it baby
hey what's up my dudes it's me i'm here
and i want to talk to you about bone
broth have you ever heard of bone broth
very nutritious very delicious very
incredible a lot of people don't know
about it but bone broth is actually
extremely nutritious it's full of
collagen and uh collagen is a
lull a collagen is good for your skin
the quality of it is
just phenomenal
everyone please stop talking i am in the
middle of something here i need to get
this through to you guys about how bone
broth really changes your entire
composition and will change your life
the best bone broth comes from really
good bones there's so much bone in the
broth that you just feel the
lusciousness of the bones and cue for
your donation but if you would rather
keep the money so that you could get
more bone broth that'd be the best there
are people who say your conversation is
boring lightly fire them i love to fall
good stream hey thank you but listen you
are not listening about the bone five
hours later okay cool
made some
baller money thanks guys thank you
i didn't make very much money i'm gonna
just eat a bunch of clam soup
off a bunch of clam soup
clam soup please
oh my soup my clams i actually don't
like clam soup but this is an alternate
reality where this could wow
nice clams
these are some sweet clay i don't want
to build it i want to eat it i eat these
clams
hell yeah i get energy from eating clams
i can stream all day baby but my health
is really not doing very good can i
afford a shower i am extremely dirty
bathtub bathtub i
i have 400
i can do that i will be very clean
tomorrow i do have to go
and
deliver
pizza but i am getting better at driving
every day's a new day every opportunity
is a new opportunity and i am destroying
everything
yes my bad
frick i'm sorry everybody holy [ __ ] i am
so strong i have a bathtub
it goes right here
boom
please oh my god
oh
oh okay i got time uh for one more bath
maybe i don't know why it takes energy
to take a bath but i know that now i
have to go to work
the grind baby the grind i know i know i
know work work work with
this place is cold i'm cold i'm cold
what does that even mean i'm cold what
do i need to go buy a jacket i guess i
am wearing like underwear why are you
walking in the street buddy hey buddy
excuse me oh my god i'm so actually
sorry i've hit people before and it
hasn't done that
you okay
oh
yeah you're fine you're fine
okay another
another good day at work all right time
to go home oh that was a bumpys curb
okay hey guys nope that's wrong
oh my god oh you
turn a boot boot her up again i guess
and i'll go
i'm just so strong that's the issue i'm
just so strong that i cloned it up right
away hygiene's good food's good energy's
good i'm ready for this i'm ready for
this baby i'm ready for the grind i'm
ready for it load her up get it going
it's youtube what if i sign up for a
zootube i put my archives up there and
you know make some more money save
stream 240.
it's it's better it's progress up hey
what's up guys it's me
back at it again i really appreciate you
coming back for another day i got a
great game in store for you it's called
dark souls and i'm really good at this
game i'm sleepy watching you thank you i
really appreciate that
thank you thank you really appreciate it
really appreciate it anyway i'm gonna
play the world's toughest game which for
some reason it is very slippery i'll get
to your donors in just a hot second
those sweet donos those sick sweet donos
oh my god oh what the hell
i appreciate the donors thank you so
much
good
okay this is actually hard i don't know
what the deal is what is what is with
this
why is this actually hard
i'll be with you in a second i'll be
with you in a moment
okay if i navigate it like that
it's not too bad oh my god okay got it
got it got it okay hey thanks for those
sick donors you guys are beyond good i
cannot stop preaching
everyone who is in here is just who god
damn amazing
is there anyone to play a game with me
only me
do not go there can i hire moderators
no i'm tired no i'm so tired okay well
i'll just leave this game here hey thank
you thank you really really preach
really appreciate hey give me your money
i'm gonna get some clams and then i'll
guess what i'm gonna be
back at it again what is up my dudes it
is time to upload my big debut and i'm
gonna pay for better internet because
that is the better way to do it
publish exactly thank you thank you i'm
tired i need rest you know what do i
though
but do i
the thing is do i sports drink that
sounds good
sports drink get some sports drinks get
some
sodies and then more clam soup baby i
know my nutritional needs and it is all
of this eventually i'll get a webcam so
my food you know this game could easily
turn into a horror game very quickly and
i would never know the difference eat it
yep eat that
that doesn't give nearly as much energy
as i thought it would it's something
it's enough to get me i've done peace
every time okay good enough time to get
back on that grind baby hey when is up
everybody it's me again whoa
yeah you know it you love it i'm here
you're here we're here let's do this
okay let's have some fun let's have some
fun today guys let's have some fun today
okay let's let's have some fun today all
right let's keep it fun let's keep it
fun today you know you know what i mean
let's just keep it fun today you know
you know what i mean let's today well
let's just keep it fun thank you hey hey
oh my god i'm sorry i no no
oh no
oh no oh god no
where's the freeze chat function oh no
at some point i'm gonna need moderators
because i literally don't think i can
you know do
anything
okay oh oh my god i was tired but hey i
got some more money baby i got some more
money and i got paid baby i got paid so
that's good let me just upload that to
the old youtubes zootubes and uh um
we'll call that a day well done look at
that exactly zero views but it's okay
hey
it's pretty good
i have a new bills
oh
i have bills electricity bill all right
yeah that's important tax bill okay fast
net bill okay that's good electricity
bill right
doing good freelancers what does this
even mean
coding
oh i do it
oh i do the coding
what
ah okay
okay
got it okay
code oh my god t
two zero
zero is that it oh
oh i have to do more oh my god code one
u x e
okay code f b
z nine
a code a a5 e6
that's it oh
no
okay that is oddly good money that it is
surprisingly good money i just got to
get better at seeing the right things
okay that's good that's a lot of money
to get
right off the bat that's nuts i could
stream that i could just dream me doing
that as a job couldn't i modders oh
hiring a moderator first oh moderator
renewal okay number of moderators
oh my god
appreciate this big breach on this big
big priest r m
f
r m f r m f x
thank you thank you what does this
crown mean okay whatever i'm gonna hire
one
two mods
and they're gonna work for me and i'm a
stream baby hey we're just browsing the
internet today you know what we're doing
we're browsing the internet you know
sometimes you just gotta browse the
internet sometimes you just gotta
get to browsing you know what i mean you
gotta get browsing horse thank you mods
by the way thank you you mods are so
good uh bet on the red horse i bet
uh
50 bucks
go go go go go go go go go go go go no
no no yes yes
yes yes yes yes no no no no no no no no
no
no no
skin case what does that even mean
oh sure
we guarantee a win to increase your
money
sure
awesome
i'm tired i guess
i made a lot of money guys this is
starting to get really easy
it's getting
super easy guys okay all right you know
hey things are looking up you know dude
i got like clams outside i got clams
yeah i got clam damn i was full of clam
thank you for the clam well time for bed
that was a well-earned day this is
actually getting a lot better i'm
shocked e
e i'm sweating why it's hot that's okay
time for stream cool
well clearly i didn't have nearly as
many uh viewers that time probably
because i was doing something incredibly
boring so turns out they don't like it
when you do incredibly boring things
that's duly noted and i will remember
that for the future i'm actually curious
to see how far i can push this uh so
i'm just gonna keep pushing it because
it's not like a well-made game but it's
not bad either it is kind of fascinating
there's a lot of elements here and a lot
of things to do and it's weirdly
captivating and i bet there's ways that
it can
really like get broken in terms of
numbers probably i kind of really want
to see where it goes i'm actually
interested in this game but obviously it
needs some grind so i'm gonna do that
grind and i'm just gonna see how far i
can push this thing because i am
honestly curious four to six days later
all right time skip i am full-blown
addicted to this game i have lost all
sensibility and i have completely gone
in headfirst and i am going to win at
this game i've figured out the right
methodology and yes there is a right
methodology to this i forgot to turn
that on but it's okay because i need a
bath anyway so uh delivering pizzas is
for [ __ ] and i ain't no [ __ ] the
real money maker is coding now if you're
asking yourself what that is well i'm
going to show you so you go to your
world wide web you go to your
freelancers and it turns out there's
jobs here who would have thought where
you can code and you can get code and
you can put in code and all you got to
do is type code and look for the capital
letters and numbers
bk is that it that's that's it literally
that's it that's it and you get money
from it easy easy my 85 bucks that's how
much money i made from doing pizza and
there's like five a day that you can get
so it's really kind of simple yeah so
this is every morning you do this and
then you stream and then streaming is
based on like what you're doing i think
but i'm not too worried about that right
now because i'm just gonna stream to
maintain my whatever the streak is and
then i'm gonna
buy some bitching equipment and i'm
gonna buy a [ __ ] in-house and then i'm
gonna buy a [ __ ] and set up and
everyone is gonna follow my stream and
i'm gonna become the biggest [ __ ] and
streamer in the [ __ ] world
[ __ ] i also have the fastest internet
now because i bought that and i can now
buy [ __ ] from zamzor that is gonna make
my stream so much better like say a
camera that's going to let people see my
beauty didn't i buy can't didn't i but
didn't i buy a
dinner
oh
that's a big webcam
[Music]
okay i did buy a camera okay so now
people are gonna see the real me okay
yeah perfect angle that's not how i put
you oh it is how i put you i'm just dumb
i don't know my perspectives okay
yeah
there's also gambling all over the
website uh internet whatever you want to
call it uh but that's for losers and
chumps i'm here for uh very solid things
like clam soup eight clam soups please
and then once that's there it's time to
stream what is up everybody it's back to
me ignore the 161 toxicity it is time to
get it going how is you do how is you do
look at this webcam how it's perfectly
positioned for my face okay so this is
actually bizarre there's a
pretty
[ __ ] counter strike
game actually in
uh
in this it's very strange um but it it
actually uh
well it don't run well because my
graphics card sucks but that's the weird
thing i want to get a better graphics
card so that this can play smoother so
that i can do better is very strange i
don't know why i'm actually
wanting to play it there's so many
people here
oh my god they're worse time for this
did i die
you son of a [ __ ] you made me die all
right well at least i'm getting tons of
donors the sweet subs and the sweetest
donors
okay so that's the one i have the mtx
950 what i should do is i should save up
for something substantial like i should
go for straight up the 2080 ta which
would take a while but you know it might
be worth the money or i could get this
now mtx go 103 which would be two ranks
up which not bad i'm doing it you know
what i'm doing i'm making the smart
order i'm not gonna wait until i get so
much money i'm not gonna it's gonna take
days it's gonna take days i don't have
days i don't understand
what's happening to me but i think i am
no i'm making a declaration i am full
balls deep into this game i have forgone
any other commitments that i've ever had
in my life and i'm going whole hog oh
did my graphics oh
oh good thing no one just snatched it
look at her boobs okay i need to shut
this down turn it off we're gonna put
that there we're gonna put this uh
i guess in the second slot uh i don't
know what good that does it's whatever
booter up next stops an ssd and uh maybe
a new cpu because my cpu is garbage
counter strika let's see if this
actually did anything differently
what is up my guys it is time once again
for your boy markiplier to come in
hot and heavy
getting it done in out and gone you love
me i love me
we all love me
thank you
thank you so
much
this is still am i cpu limited or
something is this
oh god it's barely better it is time for
another round of incredible gameplay you
go to
blender.tv
markiplier you're gonna find only the
best stuff
for you even though we got a sick defeat
you're about to see us win it till the
end all right
lots of love out there for
we win
we are the greatest and it's all thanks
to my incredible
kings out there the community of kings
there can only be one king that's me but
all of you are princes in the making
princes and princesses dukes and
duquettes
i closed the stream because i was tired
85 bucks we did not get as many people
that day that we did before and i am
wondering why that would be it's a
little bit you know kind of [ __ ] all
right time skip i have
hacked the system you go buy water and a
lot of water and then you run out of
your house and you go chug some water
and your energy stays nice and high and
then suddenly you're at like
700 viewers and you're getting the good
bank you're getting the money money ding
dong
then you i eat this i'm gonna throw this
clam soup away and i chug two more
waters i go to the turtle
and then i get back to stream and i make
more money why
am i enjoying this i don't understand am
i going down a road that i won't be able
to come back from i will be playing this
game which is
surprisingly deep it's a very small pool
but it's so deep
like it's shallow and deep at the same
time there's not a lot going on the
surface but at its core there is just
so much happening
i have over a thousand people watching
yes
i could just actually stream i could
just actually order food 205
that's not nearly as much as i was
hoping i was making what the hell this
is [ __ ] all right you know what i'm
done with this i'm done i i could see a
path where i go through this endlessly
trying to min max everything and i could
and i feel like i want to but i'm ending
it because otherwise this is going to
consume my life and then suddenly i'm
going to have an amazing house an
amazing computer and i'm going to be an
incredible streamer but on the game
where i
i can just be that in real life that's a
weirdly fun game but it's also life
consuming both the real streaming grind
and this grind so thank you everybody so
much for watching if you want to play
this linked in the description if you
want to know what the life of a streamer
is let me know down below because i
don't know yet
i haven't found the truth it's a love of
the grind i guess so thank you and as
always i'll see you
in the next video
[Music]
uh
so
as it turns out i wasn't done
i
am still playing and i am a well-oiled
streaming machine at this point i know
exactly what to do i start up my day i
get some food i get some water and i
start streaming and i get the money and
to be perfectly honest
kind of fun
when the first round's over i go eat my
food i come back i stream some more i go
to the bathroom i i just i've got quite
the routine
i read don't knows and i i just i get a
good bit of money i i soon will be able
to upgrade my graphics card to tip top
shape and that guy's rolling for some
reason
and then i go get in another round i go
to go get my food and
i eat it
clam soup all the way i guess i didn't
need that much food and for some reason
today's a high energy day then you hop
back good god guys don't don't judge me
i i don't know it's it works and it's
simple and there's other games that i
want to play but my hard drives are full
so i gotta get a new hard drive look
guys it's too real it's too real yeah so
followers have been good subs have been
good
viewer accounts
uh really no complaints yeah no no
complaints
making
good money i don't know why i'm actually
enjoying this really shitty
counter-strike knockoff i mean that's
kind of the bottom of the barrel i could
literally play counter-strike against
bots on a real stream at any second i
could just go live streaming this
and
i mean why am i not right why am i not
why am i not why am i i could i could
actually be talking to people live but
i'm not
because i'm playing this and i really
legitimately cannot tell you why fyi you
do oh what the hell what the hell you
hacking [ __ ]
with a regular pistol are you kidding
i'm raging in a
[ __ ] clone i'm
i have issues help
help
i'm gonna help
[Music]
hello i'm back again i've been playing
quite a bit i made some money moves
on the cryptocurrency exchange and now i
have 37 000
now
i'm ready to buy a house
i can get this place and its internet
speed is ungodly good i'm gonna skip all
these even this would be great the
detached hut that that sounds nice but i
have enough money to buy a house so a
big home in the most luxurious district
yeah i'm gonna do that i have a house
now
i thought that would be more fanfare to
that
is that my house house five i guess it's
time to move i've been doing this a lot
and uh i've made a lot of progress and
my car sucks and i could probably get a
new car but you know how it is it's
mashed up against this foliage i can't
oh no
hello
there we go
the slide in through the roof here
that's fine all right let me i need to
get my car because i need to pack up all
my stuff not that i have a lot but you
know how it is might as well take it i
want to start completely from scratch
oh is that an outhouse
is that an outhouse
oh my god there was a toilet here though
all
for 10 bucks for an outhouse to [ __ ] in
a hole really you know
i made a lot of memories here
i had a lot of good times a lot of
streams you always remember your first
place you started your great streaming
career and what a career it's been
it can't do this without disassembling
oh well that's
oh my god but i have so many
how do i drop things
can i oh i put it in my hand and i throw
it i think
that i think that's what i do which is
very strange
yeah
sure probably just gonna build a whole
new computer when i get there because i
have enough money to do so so
why not
but do you see how this is a problem and
whatever i i don't know
you want this take it and then my mouse
and that's all i can bring it's not like
i'm gonna be able to bring my i guess i
could make multiple trips you know i
guess that is the logical conclusion to
all this but you know i i don't know i
hope there's a bed there all right
excuse me
harden me
you might want to move just suggesting
you you should probably move man i hope
it has indoor plumbing if this house
doesn't come with toilets and like
a bathtub i'm gonna be so upset yeah so
basically i'm not gonna go back because
it would cost me more to go back than it
would just to buy some new stuff from
zamasu
oh this is lovely
oh this is delightful
this is great which one's mine okay
excuse me
excuse
me
excuse me
what
what
what what am i stuck on i guess this is
where
we end our journey
yes that's it all right hey thanks um
for the warm welcome
my home
beautiful much better than that utter
[ __ ]
oh does this mean that i can get a
fridge or something i look at this place
look at i should have looked before i
bought it but you know what i don't
regret a thing this is delightful
this ah this is goddamned that's weird
but uh this is goddamn
oh
delightful
hey how's it going neighbor how are you
doing they're coming for me okay garage
definitely not that i would have parked
my car in the garage but you know
things just don't work out that way so i
think i'm gonna set up here just because
i don't want to have to run out the door
for delivery and food and whatnot well
i mean oh i didn't bring a table
oh
can i get away without it oh no i cannot
well
all right then throw everything one at a
goddamn time oh my god this is horrible
i hate this oh but i'm not gonna be able
to drive there because my car is stuck i
now have to go get a new car
because
apparently
i bricked mine how far away is it i
wonder quietly to myself very far
extremely far away i hope i have enough
money for a car
i got like twenty thousand dollars but
is that gonna be enough for a car and i
need to get a bed because i if if i
don't sleep in a bed i don't save the
game the game only saves when you sleep
i have to run through the woods to get a
car this is going so much worse than i
had imagined that it was going to go
okay i'll get a new car i'll swing by my
old house pick up my bed toilet
bathtub and desk and chair and i'll
drive it all back and hopefully this new
car will have better handling and also
my streaming streak is going to go down
or whatever guess it's not that big a
deal guess no one really cares about it
guess it's not my problem
oh wait yes it is it's exactly my
problem
seems like there's a bit of a traffic
jam here
you guys all right man
i know i'm hungry i know i know i know
i know i can't order food on my phone so
you know kind of got to deal with it
okay what do we got
what do we got 21 000 that's expensive
uh
15 000 that's that's pretty okay
32 000 good god i mean this looks nice
but that's all my money
and this is the cheapest at a whopping
eleven thousand do i need cash do i
gotta get cash here atm
where's an
atm okay boom
boom boom
and boom okay i have enough money in my
pocket
and
bam
enter car it's mine now right
sweet
hand break off
sure doesn't sound like oh okay sure
doesn't sound like this type all right
oh my god
hey the brakes actually work on this
i can't believe that the brakes work who
would have thought what a design okay
maybe this car is better
ow
handbrake okay now we get out
hey can i get a scream could i get one
scream please thank you for the scream
appreciate that appreciate all right
for god's sake get this in my bag i'm
apparently rich now i've got my bed i
have everything i need i can just go i'm
not even gonna put in the trunk i'm just
gonna carry my bed in the car and we're
gonna go to the new place set it all up
and get the hell out of this horrible
nightmare world and leave it behind
forever
thank you everybody here and i'm sorry
that you have to live here but i've
moved on
how about i just go straight there oh
oh my god
well
yeah i think that's a good mx body yeah
that's good that's that's enough for me
i'm good all right bye
[Music]
you